everyone is warned and it's time to vote
on which theories you thought was the
best for the month of March here's a
recap of all of the theories that one
for the month of March be sure to vote
on which one you thought was your
favorite at the end
so those are all the winners for the
month of March be sure to vote on which
theory you thought was the best and
should win the overall monthly prize the
winner will receive two imax tickets so
they can go see Avengers endgame in IMAX
be sure to subscribe to my channel so
you can stay up to date on all Theory
Thursdays and all things Marvel as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
number four comes from Jeff Exodus and
Jeff believes that Loki is still alive
Jeff says I believe Loki used his
illusions and what Thanos actually broke
was the neck of one of the already dead
as guardians lying around the ship Loki
has never made a direct and obvious
straight on attack on anybody it seems
idiotic that he would falter from this
self-preservation against the mad Titan
wearing the space and the power stone
Jeff believes that the line spoken by
Thanos no resurrections this time was
needed in order for the surprise and
suspense of Loki's outcome to be there
after all the previous so-called deaths
so the question is how did Loki and
Valkyrie who was also missing get away
Jeff says that if you pay attention to
the end of Thor Ragnarok there's a quick
scene that shows the outer hull of the
Asgardian ship they use to escape
Ragnarok and like a homogeneous trikes
back where the Millennium Falcon
attaches to the Star Destroyer the
grandmasters personal ship is attached
to the outer hull just like Valkyrie it
is missing an Infinity Ward nor is there
anything in the records resembling it
there's a good chance that that's how
they escaped while Thanos was
concentrating on killing a fake Loki
this is a very interesting theory mainly
because I am one of the people who
believes that Loki isn't actually dead
and Jeff makes an excellent point when
he says that Loki has never attacked
anybody like that before and if you do
think about it it is idiotic on Loki's
part he knows who Thinnes is he knows
how strong he is he knows what the
Infinity stones are and he knows that
Thanos has two of them why would he
attack Thanos I always thought that it
was an illusion but I never thought that
it could be one of the already dead as
guardians that Loki switched it makes a
lot of sense and could quite possibly be
what actually happened
it comes from Chris and he thinks that
Ant Man is going to play a huge role in
Avengers endgame Chris says I think
ant-man is going to play a major role in
endgame in my theory he escapes the
quantum realm at least 1 to 2 years into
the future when knots
is the long red braid he rushes to the
home of Cassie and her parents to
realize it's been empty for a while the
lawn and hedges are very overgrown trash
has heaped on the curb and old weathered
missing person posters cover every space
on the pole he goes back to his office
he goes back to his home he tries to
find somebody that can fill him in I
think he finds Cassie who tells him what
she knows and Scott realizes he has to
get to the Avengers he learns though
they had already tried to fight Thanos
with new help months after the snap and
failed again and no one has heard from
them since Scott decides to return to
the quantum realm and take a new vortex
and get out closer to the snap either
through hit and miss or guidance from
somebody inside of the quantum realm
perhaps dr. strange Scott gets out three
months after the snap he drives across
the country and gets to the Avengers
headquarters where gnats hair is still
short and blond
Tony nebula and Captain Marvel have
already arrived he's suddenly in on the
initial battle against Thanos because
it's about to happen when he gets there
before he has time to tell them all that
he knows after their loss again they are
now ready to listen to Scott's
information he brings with him Pym
particles his suit in possibly
directions from contact with Hank
through a past time vortex on how to
create the suits Tony takes often
develops a multi-purpose quantum realm
slash space suit for all the Avengers
while NAT goes to find Clint thorn
rocket find Valkyrie and Captain Marvel
recruits scroll and other cosmic allies
so this is Chris's theory and I think
that it makes a lot of sense primarily
because I don't think ant-man is going
to get it right jumping through a time
vortex the first time he's not going to
automatically land in the perfect time
he's going to get it wrong at first
because at first he won't have any
control over the time vortex but I agree
that he will eventually have control
over a time vortex somehow and that is
when he'll go to the Avengers
headquarters and fill them in on
everything and I do personally think
that the Avengers are going to fight
Thanos more than once in Avengers in
game I do think they'll lose at first so
I think that this theory makes a lot of
sense theory comes from Walker and he
says that Thanos will kill Captain
Marvel in the beginning of Avengers
endgame this is how Walker says that
it's going to go down we see Carole
arrived at the Avengers headquarters
right after that Oh snaps his fingers
and the new in-game trailer we see
banter between Carole and Thor this is a
scene that was exactly
scribed in the shareholders meeting but
nebula was explaining that Thanos would
be in his garden this scene we assumed
that Captain America Black Widow nebula
warmachine Thor and Rocket Raccoon and
Captain Marvel are going to fly to space
to Titan to to fight Thanos when they
get to Titan to in Thanos his garden
Thanos seized them and they lock eyes
for a few seconds as he addresses
everybody he does a head gesture towards
Thor but he notices someone new he
instantly knows who she is because of
the full gauntlet and lets out a smile
Carroll rushes him but he knocks her
down easily after the heroes fight he
picks up Carol's beaten body and starts
choking her and ends up killing her he
then gives the Avengers a chance to
leave or he will kill them this is the
defeat that makes them just give up then
ant-man gets out of the quantum realm
they travel back in time ultimately
defeat Thanos and bring everybody back
walkers reasoning behind this theory is
that in the battle scene and the suit
seen in the trailers we see all the main
heroes except for one Captain Marvel
also if they had Captain Marvel why
would they just give up and let a year
pass she wouldn't let that happen she
would do anything to restore the
universe and when they save her she will
repay them by agreeing to protect the
earth in the future by becoming a new
Avenger this could possibly happen
because Carol Danvers thinks that she is
invincible so she could very much
underestimate the power of Thanos and
the Risser brothers said that this movie
is going to be all about the original
six Avengers so maybe she does get
defeated in the beginning and killed but
when the Avengers bring everybody back
if they bring her back - and at the end
they all fight together and Kevin Feige
has recently said that Carol Danvers
will have a kryptonite in Avengers end
game and maybe Thanos knows what that is
theory number two comes from Nico
Gonzales and Nico says that an Avengers
in game Tony will record the message we
see in the first trailer for Pepper then
start thinking about all the things that
have happened up to this point him
becoming Iron Man
saving the world multiple times fallen
in love with pepper and then he
remembers the dream that he had about
having a child with pepper after this he
stands up and realizes that nebula has
been watching him he walks past her and
she asks him where he's going and he
says I'm not going to die like this
he starts tinkering with a part of the
ship and nebula taps him on the shoulder
he turns around to see nebula holding
Rockets toolbox and she says I'll help
cut - later Tony and nebula land
Lokhande and are instantly charged at by
the remaining people of Wakanda having
just lost most of their people that what
Condon's don't know who to trust Tony
and nebula fend off a few but soon they
are surrounded by the whole Condon's and
one of them yells state your purpose
Tony says we just returned from fighting
an alien with a glorified mitten the
wakandans realizing Tony is on their
side explain what happened and Tony says
I need to find the Avengers but first I
need a new suit the wakandans give Tony
anything he needs to make his new suit
eventually Tony asked for the strongest
metal that they have and they give Tony
a dimension they call it a sacred metal
in which is stronger than vibranium and
even they don't have a lot of it
Tony studies the vibranium and Adam in
tiem and figures out that there are both
advantages and disadvantages to both so
he ends up using both in the suit and
calls it the bleeding edge armor I like
this theory especially since I've done a
video on how Tony Stark could possibly
make a vibranium Iron Man suit it would
make sense that at some point in time
Tony
ends up in Wakanda they're the most
technologically advanced city in the
world and Tony is going to need a better
suit to fight Thanos since he already
lost with his old suit and it would be
crazy cool if somehow the wakandans had
adamantium which would be a little node
to Wolverine so this is something I
could definitely see happening and I
really would hope they would say
something about adamantium
[Music]
[Music]